it is a highly controversial policy a
plane taking off to Rwanda that's my
dream the strong feelings on both sides
[Music]
after months of deliberation today A
high court decision sending Asylum
Seekers to Rwanda is legal how did you
feel when you heard the drug this
morning it must have been a blow
we just feel utterly disappointed like I
say our country can do better why are we
looking at something that is going to
cost our country billions and not
achieve anything nobody believes they're
around a plan but it's going to stop
some more about Crossings
but the government believe it will work
since months since a late night appeal
grounded the first Rwanda flight
the prime ministers later and Richie
soon act today in Latvia made clear
immigration at home is a personal
priority I welcome the decision of the
court today we've always maintained that
our Rwanda policy is lawful I'm pleased
that was confirmed today and this is
just one part of our plan to tackle
illegal migration but successive Prime
Ministers haven't solved the issue of
Migrant Crossings last week four lives
lost a reminder of how dangerous the
journey is the court also ruled that the
cases of eight Asylum Seekers will be
reconsidered the government could end up
locked in legal action in practice
though couldn't the government have to
justify every single case every single
person they want to support any
individual has uh is able to bring a
judicial review claim that's how the
legal system works in the UK and if the
home office fails to consider their case
and their personal circumstances
properly then they would have grounds to
bring a judicial review challenging that
decision we cannot tolerate people
coming here illegally the Home Secretary
today wouldn't confirm when the first
flight will leave the sooner it is up
and running the sooner we will break the
business model of the evil gangs that
says she's ready to defend the policy
again in court
the Rhonda plan has become symbolic of
something much bigger for a prime
minister who wants to be seen to be
tough on immigration he knows that this
is something that comes up with the
electorate on the doorstep Something
That Matters to many conservative MPS
and while today is a victory for the
government there are still questions
about whether the Rwanda plan really is
workable
the pm has pledged to clear the Asylum
backlog he's talked of a deal with
Albania too
whatever the policy success will be
judged by images like this whether the
government can stop people risking
everything to make it to the UK Ali
Fortescue Sky News